so that south african variant 351
is now dominant in south africa
and causing the vast majority of the
cases
that they encounter it has been detected
in the uk
but in very small numbers and it is not
our dominant virus our dominant virus at
the moment
is a variant which was first identified
in kent
which you'll be aware of and we call
that one be 1.117
and you will know from
what we saw before christmas with the
117 variant that if it has
a distinct transmissibility advantage
over the predecessor then it can
establish itself
very quickly indeed
but early data on modeling
of b1.351 does not
suggest this is so does not suggest
that the south african variant has
a distinct transmissibility advantage
over our current virus and because of
that
there is no reason to think the south
african variant
will catch up or overtake our current
virus
in the next few months and that's a
really important point
that being the case our immediate threat
is from our current virus and
there is now plenty of evidence that the
vaccines that we are deploying
are effective against our current
virus so from that perspective
look please don't delay if you're called
take the advantage to protect yourself
against the clear and present danger
against the immediate threat